hey guys this is andrew for
trainingsenses.com i've been working as
a professional trader for the past six
years in hong kong
and i've just started to make youtube
videos where i want to share with you
guys
all my experience i want to show you how
pro trainers actually work
and what kind of tools and techniques we
use to make money on the markets
so if you want to know about all uh the
stuff you are in the right place
today i want to talk about the weed
stocks all right because this is a very
hot topic
uh this week we had some crazy moves
about it so i want to go through
the news and the reasons actually why
this move
happened and if it's gonna keep
happening let's get into it
[Music]
so first i selected some wheat stocks
all right the biggest one so we have
tire
afria canopy gross and nsdl i'm going to
talk about all of this there are other
stocks i want to talk about but i'm
going to talk about this later and i'm
going to show you
some key figures so first i want to talk
about the news
so basically just the kind of moves that
we saw is like strong moves up so for
example for tier
we had around 150 up in a matter of a
few days all right
so what is the reason behind that the
first reason as you can see guys the
earnings
are very negative for all of the stocks
they basically
have a lot of debt and they are you know
sending marijuana
so medical and recreative but you know
they just borrow so much money to make
the weed grow
that for now they're not profitable this
is the issue they have and
for now they cannot sell to everybody
because it's not legal
so for the first time they had positive
earnings the tierra said it delivered
2.2 million in adjusted abda so it's the
earning before interest taxes
depreciation and amortization
so basically they are positive all right
and this is
the first time it happened to a weed
company so this is kind of to me the
sparkle that started this big rally and
of course we have something more general
uh we have some uh hopes of legalization
in
a lot of a lot of states of the united
states
but guys we always have this kind of you
know for example
analysts that say that is far from
guaranteed and could be years away
ambitious
legislation nationally or in individual
states often
on the goes assuring on his journey to
signature u.s lawmakers we have
other battles all right so basically
this is telling us that
it can take time but guys when analysts
are not confident
and you know there are some hopes this
is the typical situation
where you know investors buy the rumor
and maybe they're gonna end up selling
the news i don't know
but for now this is a rumor and this
stuff is going up
so is this gonna keep happening
i don't know for now you know it's not
enough to say but what we can say
is that this is hot guys everybody's
talking about it for example we have
this guy
so i i discovered this guys not long ago
he's zac maurice
so he has a twitter page with like four
hundred thousand followers
so basically everybody that told me
about this guy they call him
mr zachmarys master uh the oracle
you know so they have faith in him and
you know because he basically helped
them
to make a lot of money so the
description of this guy the master furu
i'm not a financial advisor i post most
ideas on twitter
my twitter opinions only do your own dd
and stop being a little [ __ ]
so you can see the mindset you know he's
very like kind of you know he played
cool
you know he posts some stuff about weed
you know so he is
amongst those people who are actually
pushing this market up just by talking
about it by tweeting
about the stuff you can see for example
the
kind of stuff he he's posting dude just
file your 30g
for fubo and send it to 100. so you know
they just want to
push the stocks higher so he's talking
about fubu tv i did a video on this one
i'm gonna make
a new update very soon for example you
can find stuff like this
about this guy so they said that his
average
six months gain at 240 all right and
they describe everything so basically
they take his idea and they
check what the stocks how performing
were
the the stocks he talked about and you
have some comments
for example about this guy all right so
this is 17
17 of february so this is just a few
days ago
i don't believe his gain is only 243
percent over six months
i am on 700 in two months from his calls
all right
and i heard a lot of people that follow
this guy right people in my family
people like my some close friends and
they all telling me
this guy you know has some information
when you try
to check some information about him you
only find that he
is uh an actor born in 1974
all right so this guy he said this are
all pictures
and i don't really know if it's really
him or not if but what i know is that
it looks like he is an amazing day
trader and even like
long-term trader so i'm not exactly sure
how
who is this guy and is he really making
money with stocks
but what i see is that he's
often right and so he is an amazing
trader to me and
there is a lot of good information to
find on his to the page
whether we have we have stuff like this
you know so i saw this picture
uh you know this meme uh a lot of times
this week so you can
find here on the ass of the girl the
dips you can find with stock
you can find amc you know everything
everything that is hot basically and you
always have this priest that is
basically trying
not to be tempted me trying to live a
normal productive life
all right guys this is once again very
interesting because
it's the mindset of all these investors
they want to get rich
but not the clean way you know they
don't want to work hard and you know
just have a salary they want to make it
the dirty way
all right that's where you have this
kind of pictures and they're very
tempted to just put all of the money in
something that is hot
and to just [ __ ] the world sorry for my
language but this is exactly the mindset
they they they have so yeah we are in
this environment so the wheat stocks are
pushed
by this kind of you know investors by
this kind of
guru zach maurice and on reddit you have
a lot of stuff about it on wall street
bets they talk about wheat stocks
uh and as well as other hot stocks this
is for me a reason
for this stocks to have these crazy
moves so very quickly i'm gonna talk
about the market capitalization so till
rate has
1.2 billion all right so it's a small
cap we have afria and canopy growth
that are bigger they have six and 15
billion
uh and we have an sndl the zac maurice
is talking a lot about this one
and they have two billion in market
capitalization all right
the short interests are not that big you
know t-rex
has 30 so it's the biggest one so
basically i found this uh
information on this uh stock i go on
market bit for example i type
t-rex so this is accessible to everyone
guys it's free so i
encourage you to go there i've
cross-checked this data with bloomberg
i'm not allowed to use bloomberg for my
research here
but i just cross checked the data and
it's very close it's not
exactly the same it's very close so this
data is good to use guys
so then you type your stock and you go
to short interest
and here you can find for example
children they have 23 percent of shares
shorted uh and the the time it was
updated was the 29th
of january guys all right so you can
find a lot of information and the market
cap is
here so this is 4.2 kilo rain
4.2 billion sorry i did a typo all right
so here we are
so it's 4 billion so it's still a small
cap it's
uh bigger than smdl though but
what is interesting guys is as well to
check the
volumes all right so if i check
so uh let's do a bit of technical
analysis
so here i have the earnings so like i
said very negative guys they're losing
uh 700 million so this is annual figures
reported every quarter but this is
annualized so
it's big losses and you can see guys
that here
the stock did some crazy moves recently
so like i said around 120
120 higher in a matter of days and you
can see the volumes traded guys it's
around
180 million shares all right so
if the shares is worth 50 dollars this
makes us
around 10 billion us dollar traded
then what i do i compare this
volume to the market cap guys and i can
see
so this gives me this number and i can
see guys that
you know this is basically more than 200
of the market cap more than twice the
market cap all right
so of course you understand that if
there is such a big volume traded
it can only push the stock higher guys
you know it's like
for example nsdl they had i'm going to
go through this
as well but they have around 100 50 150
of the total market cap that is traded
in a matter of
one day guys all right so this is insane
and for example africa and canopy growth
they have much smaller volumes
so to me those stocks because the market
cap is bigger as well
uh so those stocks it's going to be hard
to really push them just by uh talking
about it
which is not true for any sndl and t-rex
so to me those stocks are hot
and they are the winners of my analysis
i'm going to go again through technical
very soon
just to compare amc for example they had
250
so it's the same kind of stuff gme 500
and if you want to
see something normal tesla which is
trading sometimes 200 billion us dollar
a day but they have a much bigger market
cap have around 25
as of the total market cap traded in one
day this is the maximum that i saw uh in
a one-year chart
so you can see that this is insane guys
all right this is
much much bigger than what we usually
see
now what should we do guys so the rally
already
happened all right and the correction as
well so you can see
lost 50 almost so i'm doing the usual
stuff guys all right
so trend line i'm gonna
i'm on the logarithmic scale and i just
trying to find the breakout so the
breakout is
here definitely so this is now support
all right and you can see guys as usual
we broke the the trend line so this was
like in november in november what
happened they
announced that they're gonna have
positive earnings next year
so you know once again this is a rumor
and actually the news has been confirmed
and bought even
more then we break it we retest we go
higher
so now guys this rally is to me
missed so it's too late to enter if
you're long
don't sell i mean sell if you want i'm
not again giving
advice but i wouldn't sell it because
it's still hot you know
everybody's talking about it so it might
push higher
if you're not long where can you buy the
stuff i just put so here you can see
that
you have a nice resistance level uh for
the
during the first runny we went there
rejected
and then we go higher and this was the
maximum level that we had here
and then we go higher with a gap up you
know so this is confirming
that this is a very strong uh resistance
that that is now support
has it been retested not yet not yet
guys and
where is the stock going it's going
there so i think it might
lose you know 20 more so guys don't
panic if this happens it's
normal and then i think that we're gonna
have fresh buyers that end to this level
and if you want to be one of those you
can buy around 22
23 put a stop loss at 20 all right so 10
15
loss and you can make 130 for the first
first level
and the second level is 300 all right
how do i find this levels as usual guys
i take the maximum that we had you know
during the
move down and i tried to find when i had
some consolidation so here maximum
then the consideration is not very
obvious but here we have also this
maximum
so this is definitely a resistance level
and the next one is
uh at the almost all-time highs here
guys
all right i'm done with uh children so
afria
so there are some rumors that tyre is
actually gonna merge with afria so this
goes together
same thing negative earnings but it's
probably going to get positive
especially if marijuana is
selling more in those states that gonna
legalize it
in terms of volume traded we are
reaching
uh for afria 30 so you know this one is
not hot all right
so i wouldn't go for this one go for
tiller if you want to choose
but we have the same kind of technicals
uh which means
trend line broken you know
here not retested yet then we go higher
so don't think we're gonna retest this
one here
we go through the all-time high and now
we are we are consolidating here
so i don't know what's gonna happen with
the staff but if
everything you know confirms in the weed
market
which eventually will happen one day
guys you know a lot of people smoke weed
and you know it's a very big market they
put the money to make it grow in the
good way and to sell all the accessories
and you know you know in a clean way
so i believe in the long term uh in this
market so we might see a breakout and
just you know the stock rallying
uh even more i don't i don't really have
strong levels on this one to be honest
so canopy growth cooperation all right
so this one is the biggest one so you
know they're losing four billion guys
totally i mean it's annualized but last
quarter so it's like
massive massive massive losses that's
why it was short
that much and this one it didn't breach
the all-time high got rejected
and so i didn't put any trend line here
so let me do it just right now what do i
see here
this one is working here here here
little bit
there is nothing that obvious here but
if you want to find a buying levels this
one could be good or the moving averages
but then you will need to
wait a bit guys uh the technicals are
weak for this one to be honest
i wouldn't go into this right now once
again i would go to tilore all right
this is my winner this is
to me the king of the wheat stocks uh
what for what reasons guys
because it's the one that is trading the
most in percentage of the market cap
all right so and the volume the max
volume was 10 billion all right so it's
much bigger than all the
four even the three order put together
it's less than what till ray did in one
day guys so let me finish with this
and sndl so zac maurice is talking
a lot about this one and for a long time
guys all right
so he spotted this rally i guess a lot
of people made money
uh with that so what do i see here guys
same thing we have uh you know a
downward sloping trend line that has
been broken
so it was broken here
all right the retest was not clean and
then we go higher and we are breaking
the levels one by one so now the next
support level is at 130 guys all right
we broke this one
it was the maximum level that we had
here one two three times
four times consolidation let me let me
zoom in a bit into this
we had this consolidation here and then
we broke it so guys
probably here we're gonna have a lot of
uh support uh a lot of buyers coming at
the support level
so i'm quite bearish for the very short
term but i'm very bullish in the long
term and once again
everybody talks about it and mister the
master zach maurice is talking about
that as well guys
and this guy is this guy is followed by
a lot of people
so that's it for me uh i'm done with the
witch talks
uh i hope this analysis helped you guys
to see you know what are the important
things to look at
so the volume how to analyze the volume
you need to compare it
to the market cap and see compared to
the other stocks
if which one is the hottest and my
winner is til ray
so if you enjoyed this video please
don't forget to click the like
sub and bell button so you're going to
be the first to know when i upload
anything new
and stay close to shore i see you guys